you haven't fully left housewives behind
because your date tonight is Brandi
Glanville Brandi Glanville stepping out
to support her former Real Housewives
co-star Kim Richards at the premiere of
wheat TVs of marriage boot camp reality
stars either we move forward oh we don't
you did this show before she did this
show did you give any advice to Kim
about doing the show cause the advice to
keep that be Jane Cameron to myself but
everyone that works in the scenes here
are we there awesome
and I said you're in the best hands just
you know be careful of your cast mates
because you're living in a house yeah
pit stop I can get pissed off I'm tired
of it no when you did this show you did
it with your dad and what's the
relationship status today and I we've
left the show in a great space and then
when the show aired we haven't talked
since really you haven't talked to your
dad Sam yeah okay Wow why is that um you
know he doesn't he's not done TV before
and I warned him ahead of time I said
you they're not gonna be able to show
everything that we shot they're gonna
show the highlights so you have to write
down notes and understand it's gonna be
the highlights of what was shot and
don't get mad you're gonna get mad all
over again and ultimately he did I think
quite some time and unfortunately I'm
used to face like I'm it's housewives
all I like I can handle it for him I
think he cares about his friends and
everyone were saying about what they saw
and I thought hey they gave him a great
attitude be honest because he was a
little bit worse but no we haven't
unfortunately but I thought Kennedy
really everything and you have hope that
that will get into a better place sooner
rather than later I'm just I'm leaving
it in his in his corner because you know
you don't mean I get a low aggressive
Brandis dad guy Glanville has not
publicly spoken out about her claims but
brandi is talking to et about a
different man in her life I feel like I
saw you posting with a new man on social
media is there any guy in your life
I'm dating for sure and like it's just
we just hang out like it's not like
we're he's on on social media he's not
like the last time / to social media so
this one's just like he's like he's
European his first language is French so
we don't really understand each other
and that's probably why we hang out so
much because I'm like I don't know
anything you just said but you're cute
so you can say okay so it's more
physical than anything right now
I adore him but yeah it's physical he's
like 10 years younger and he's very
athletic okay we're having fun we're
having fun people yes
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]